[Music]
what's up guys I'm going to be showing
you a brand new video of how to make
money super fast super easy with little
requirements so we're going to be buying
dwarf cannons from the dwarfs near the
monastery so you need your combat
bracelet and a ring of dueling so
teleport to the monastery and run
directly
Southwest to this little um not a bridge
but a little pathway and run up here and
so the only requirements for this is
that you do the dwarf Cannon
Quest and I'll leave that in the
description and so you run over here and
you want to bring your money with
you as much money as you can you need to
have a minimum of
750k so click him and then click the
space bar and then click one when words
pop up keep clicking in 750 coins th000
coins click one again keep doing it and
then he'll sell you a cannon and so you
cannot have a cannon in your bank or in
your inventory while you're doing this
so you need to drop all the Canon Pieces
Just click drop click space click one
drop them all and then leave the ammo
and stuff in your inventory we'll drop
that
later and just keep doing
this and it'll take about a minute to
get three cannons so I'll show you when
I'm done okay guys I'm done so now I'm
just picking up the Cannons off the
floor and I only had enough money to buy
three of them so once you pick up your
cannons go go ahead and drop this stuff
cuz you don't need it and then teleport
back to the Grand
exchange and what you're going to want
to do you want to want to click sets on
the grand exchange
people sets and then you're going to
want to click the top left for the the
cannon and it'll put them in little sets
and then right now they're selling for
um 770k but let's just put them in for
765k so we can just kind of sell them
pretty quickly and so that's a 15K plus
so that's 4 5K you'll make per this so
I'll let these sell okay so they sold so
let's do the 750k that I bought all
three of them for so it'll be 2.25 mil
so we'll do the 2 295 mil that we just
sold these for
minus the
225 mil so 45k and it took me about a
minute to do this so we'll do the
45k times 60 minutes
60 so 2.7 mil so that's a lot of money
but we're going to keep doing this and
we're going to see how much more money
we can make and I'll show you guys so I
sold these ones for 766k
each sold these ones for 769k
each sold these ones for 769k each also
but I also sold one of them for
770k sold these ones for 769k
so overall I sold a bunch of
them didn't take long I did this over
about a 30 minute period so it's very
easily to do this hourly and still make
money so if we were to do the 3 for
769k instead of the 765k that's 2307 so
minus the
225 mil that we spent that's 57k * 60
minutes so that's a 3 4 mil per hour
method thanks for watching guys stay
tuned for my next video